anyone who is fully vaccinated can
participate in indoor
and outdoor activities large or small
without wearing a mask or physical
distancing
that is the big news out of the cdc for
those who are fully
vaccinated guidelines now say indoor
mass restrictions can be rolled back
under certain conditions
thanks for joining us here at five i'm
denise faldis and i'm brian loftis
governor sysolak says nevada will be
following the latest recommendations
from the cdc
but private organizations are able to
keep mass policies
in place if they wish to do so christian
costars joining us live from our
newsroom
to explain these new changes well let me
tell you it's a step that so many of us
have been looking for according to the
cdc
if you're fully vaccinated and have
waited the two weeks
that they require you are now allowed to
do this a sign of relief
taking your mask off while you are
indoors
and of course social distancing
regardless of
the crowd side now the changes were
announced this afternoon by the centers
of disease and control and prevention
they added that even with these
restrictions rollbacks fully vaccinated
people must still cover their faces
and socially distance when going to the
doctors
hospitals or places like nursing homes
now in terms of traveling the cdc
recommends
you still use the face covering on the
bus on the train
or plane which also includes airports
and bus stations
now these changes made many nevadans
smile today but some tell us they are
still not ready to toss their masks away
i just feel safer with the mask on even
even if i'm vaccinated i
i don't know i just i just feel safe i
will definitely use it
all year i don't care i'll use it every
as long as i need to well we got similar
responses from many locals today on
these changes now the cdc hopes that
fully vaccinated people
can start doing things that they stop
doing because of the pandemic
and slowly transition back to normal now
back out here live
the cdc also hopes these changes will
also promote
more americans not yet vaccinated to
take that leap we will talk more about
that
coming up at six o'clock christian
gossip is 8 news now